but let's let's start with the first
story so so this story from Fox News
sources believe coronavirus originated
in Wuhan lab as part of China's efforts
to compete with the u.s. you see that
byline right there
bret baier that to me is what made this
legit bret baier is like a
straightforward news guy yeah that's
what I when I first said it I was like
yeah but it's the news like how do I
know I can trust it and you're like it's
Bret Baier I'm like for real oh look
doesn't mean anything to me though so I
mean for those out there I'm clearly Tim
believes him because he's like a
straight shooter he's boring yeah
tonight to the point he's boring yeah
right that's not an insult that's
respect
yeah that's he's like that's the kind of
news anchor that we need right now not
trying to spin something not trying to
lie to anybody just here's the truth
these are the facts look that's the news
I don't read it I don't know a whole lot
about Bret and I'm wondering if like hey
do I got this guy wrong is he really
like some crazy opinionated guy but the
reason I don't think too much about him
is because whenever I watch him he's
just basically reading the news there's
nothing like and so it's like out of
sight out of mind almost okay and so
I've seen other people praising him even
on the left and he's not one of these
primetime you know opinion pundits okay
he's like a regular news guy very dry
very straightforward he's reporting this
this means it is bigger than its bigger
than the other reporting
I didn't think these they were they
existed still straight news guys yeah ya
know because they're all becoming so
desperate no no but you've got what like
Bill Hemmer I think is his name you've
got a handful of straightforward news
people over at Fox yes so they're out
there yeah and there and there have been
you know as much as the left likes to
rag on Fox you've got these professors
these liberal journalism professors
praising daytime Fox News for being kind
of boring just like straight for it but
anyway Brett reports this he says
exclusive kovat 19 originated in a Wuhan
laboratory not as a bio weapon but as
part of China's efforts to demonstrate
that its efforts to identify and combat
viruses are equal to or greater than the
capabilities of the US multiple sources
have been briefed on the details of
early actions by China's government and
seen relevant materials tell Fox News
this may be the quote costly event
cover-up
all time one of the one of the sources
said the sources believe the initial
transmission of the virus was bat to
human and that patient zero worked at
the laboratory then went into the
population in Wuhan now let's address
the anonymous sourcing thing which I'm
not a big fan of same here when you see
these stories you always got a look at
the byline that's what that's that's
what you're trying to do you know derive
your trust from you see the New York
Times do this all the time saying an
unnamed source you know my favorite line
I think this is the New York Times they
said according to sources familiar with
Trump's thinking like there's a real
line what that's embarrassing I can read
his mind bret baier on the other hand
though it's a straightforward news guy
who's been praised by many people and
many partisans on both sides and this is
where you can trust if he's saying he's
seen these documents and he thinks this
is of merit then i'm inclined to believe
it there's a lot of people that could
have come out and said this and i'd roll
my eyes but bret baier he's got you know
he's got 1.4 million Twitter followers
he is a very high profile
straightforward news guy I don't know
how to tell you man you know what we
ultimately choose to trust reporters
this is a major mainstream news
organization telling us this yeah that's
pretty huge asked by Fox News's John
Roberts about the reporting president
Trump remarked at Wednesday's
coronavirus press briefing more and more
were hearing the story we are doing a
very thorough examination of this
horrible situation documents detail
early efforts by doctors at the lab and
early efforts at containment the Wuhan
wet market initially identified as a
possible point of origin never sold bets
and the sources tell Fox News that
blaming the wet market was an effort by
China to deflect blame from the
laboratory along with the country's
propaganda efforts targeting the US and
Italy makes sense that's why they were
so quick to ban the consumption and wild
animals because they wanted to solidify
that story was that quick though
wouldn't it yeah it was anyway within a
month I mean for them to do that at all
yeah it says a lot so even even that
they did it all I'm seeing now is
they're just trying to solidify this
deflection make it make it the story
yeah yeah well hold on whoa so now we're
blaming the the wild animals so we won't
eat wild animals anymore that doesn't
even matter check out this story from
the AAP what Fox is reported is in a
sense corroborating other reporting from
The Associated
China didn't warn public of likely
pandemic for six key days check this out
president xi jinping warned the public
on the seventh day January 20th but by
that time more than three thousand
people had been infected during almost a
week of public silence according to
internal documents obtained by The
Associated Press and expert estimates
based on a retrospective infection data
six days that delay from January 14th to
January 20th was neither the first
mistake made by Chinese officials at all
levels in crunch confronting the
outbreak nor the longest lag as
governments around the world have
dragged their feet for weeks and even
months and dressing this virus but take
a look at that date the delay was from
January 14th on the 14th they knew and
you know what the World Health
Organization did on the 14th oh yeah
here's the tweet 6:18 a.m. Eastern Time
so what time was it over in in China 6
p.m. yeah yeah I think I think there 12
hours yeah here's what it says
preliminary investigations conducted by
the Chinese authorities have found no
clear evidence of human to human
transmission of the novel coronavirus
identified in Wuhan sounds to me like
the World Health Organization was
purposefully misleading us with the very
least useful idiots for the Chinese
government you know who knew according
to the Associated Press and withheld the
information but then why would the World
Health Organization say this to us
exactly I want to think about it is the
World Health Organization lying to us
they said China told him this right
that's what they said yeah all right
well on the 14th China knew there was
human human transmission did China lie
to the World Health Organization or did
they know the truth and then and who
then lied to the rest of us somebody
lied I bet they lied to the whu-oh who
then just believed it and they're like
oh yeah they're scientists said it yeah
I mean the optimism in me like I'm I
want to believe them but I don't know
because I so I have a hard time trusting
anything right now until seeing that
like the actual proof this crazy because
let me let me liberate this year says
u.s. embassy embassy officials warned in
January 2018 about inadequate safety at
the Wuhan Institute of virology lab
passed on information about scientists
conducting risky research on coronavirus
from Metz The Washington Post reported
Tuesday this is all now being
corroborated I think it's funny that we
all knew this you know and I'm gonna
give a I'm gonna give a nice hard
shoutout to people over at YouTube who
are too dumb to let the people who do a
good job on your platform report the
news cuz as you guys have may have heard
from the rest of us whenever we try and
report on this we get suppressed we get
D ranked or D monetized you know welcome
welcome to our YouTube functions now
months after the fact when we were doing
reporting saying hey this looks like it
may be possible we're now seeing
mainstream confirmation of what most of
us already knew you called incredible
well I mean I was skeptical and even
Senator Tom cotton was like we gotta
entertain the possibility you know this
is a thing they're doing we even had
that story from nature let me see if I
have this to it if I have this pulled up
there we go nature calm inside the
Chinese lab poised to study the world's
most dangerous dangerous pathogens from
the 23rd of February 2017 maximum
security bio lab is part of a plan to
build a network bsl-4 facilities across
China and this is a laboratory in Wuhan
and you know it's the funniest thing
about these people nature.com went back
in in January I guess and they edited
they editorialized the article editor's
note January 2020 many stories have
promoted an unverified theory that the
Wuhan lab discussed in this article
played a role in the krona virus
outbreak that began in December 2019
nature knows of no evidence this is true
scientists believe the most likely
source of the krona virus to be an
animal market why would they add that or
no reason was it what scientists Chinese
scientists right mm-hmm
because that's what the w-h-o said that
that they got their information from why
why go back to 2017 and edit this
article the information was sound
correct yeah then why change the source
if we have information that could
provide context going back and changing
it is suspect easy dude yep totally
agree and you know it's really funny to
the New York Times and CNN will like
stealth edit articles that's when they
don't let you know they changed things
okay but here we get this editors note
we just wanna let you know January 2010
I just got busted what day in January -
cuz ya was a crazy month end of the
month I'd imagine CNN RIT we've got got
busted riding a chinese propagandize
news yeah
you mean Z Z n n CN n and yeah GN n
that's going around it's pretty funny
check this out reporting we're all I'm
sorry responding to the report general
mark Milley the chairman of the Joint
Chiefs of Staff said Tuesday afternoon
it should be no surprise to you that we
have taken a keen interest in that and
we've had a lot of intelligence take a
hard look at that I would just say at
this point it's inconclusive although
the weight of evidence seems to indicate
natural but we don't know for certain
Americans were originally helping train
the Chinese in a program called prevent
well before the Chinese started working
on this virus the French government
helped the Chinese at the Wuhan lab
China quote 100% suppressed data and
changed a to the sources tell Fox News
samples were destroyed contaminated
areas scrubbed some early reports erased
an academic articles stifled there were
doctors and journalists who were
disappeared warning of the spread of the
virus and its contagious nature and
human human transmission China moved
quickly to shut down travel domestically
for a move on to the rest of China but
did not stop international flights from
Wuhan additionally the source tells Fox
News the World Health Organization was
complicit from the beginning
helping China cover its tracks Trump
announced the White House coronavirus
news briefing in the Rose Garden on
Tuesday that the United States will
immediately halt all funding for the WHO
saying it had put political correctness
over life-saving measures the United
States is the Hoos largest single donor
and the State Department had previously
planned to provide the agency 893
million dollars in the current two-year
funding period senior administration
administration separately tell Fox News
the rollout of the president's blueprint
for reopening the US economy will happen
Thursday afternoon first for governors
and then briefed to the press they say
meanwhile Trump's own handling of the
crisis has come into focus
On January 24th for example Trump
tweeted in praise of China's
transparency on coronavirus though they
were not speaking for the president the
sources ventured an explanation saying
it was diplomatic to make the Chinese
feel good while the investigation was
ongoing with trade and other talks
happening
maleeh in the six days after top Chinese
officials secretly determined they were
likely facing a pandemic from a new
corona virus the city of Wuhan at the
epicenter of the disease hosted a mass
banquet for tens of thousands of people
millions began travelling through for a
Lunar New Year celebration they knew
they had to have expected what was gonna
happen
yeah or wanted it to happen a little the
fact that they shut down travelling from
Wuhan to anywhere else in China and then
let anyone in Wuhan know you're leaving
China okay we don't care yeah that's
international flights go for where you
are you kidding me
it's like now it's like it got out and
they were like oh it wasn't supposed to
get out on our our territory
well let's contain it as much as
possible and hope it hurts them more
than it hurts us exploiting it that's
what it feels like that's why it's kind
of crazy to me that that they're saying
it was an accident because like you put
all these stories man yeah you're saying
that they were withholding information
which hurt us and caused massive damage
yep that you know BuzzFeed news reported
that Chinese trolls were trying to slow
down the response in Italy in Taiwan
that's a that's an act of aggression
yeah why so so it's weird to me for me
to assume that like some dude slips on a
banana peel
you know this accident results in this
major pandemic and then there's like
let's roll with it I mean I guess it's
possible but it's like you're saying
that everything they're doing to hurt us
in this yeah was like just fortuitous
for them I mean they're its basically
moves of war they're moving the chess
pieces and we're just trying to you know
we're not even realizing we're playing
this game right now well I think our
military does I absolutely agree that's
why they came down and that the naval
guy yeah so we must look so what's truly
fascinating about this story is that
numerous mainstream outlets have slowly
been walking towards this this theory
for a long time I mean I talked about
this months ago no because we had a
report that a researcher said here's
what we think happened trying to
suppress the study now we have more
mainstream reporting but Lotus April 3rd
the trail leading back to the Wuhan labs
and then also the same thing like we
can't prove it we can't prove it but
here's more evidence and here's more
evidence you know I think at a certain
point it's really it's really
fascinating to me how the media handles
these
because they they they you it's like a
dam of breaking almost okay you can see
on the other side all of these bits of
evidence piling up you get to a point
where a reasonable person says I think I
know what happened but the media won't
say it until finally they have a smoking
gun all of a sudden that it's mainstream
boom just one ding so now I see people
on Twitter are going nuts with this
thanks for checking out this clip from
the Tim cast IRL podcast we do the show
live Monday through Friday at 8 p.m. if
you want to catch the full show tune
into this channel subscribe hit the like
button or check us out on iTunes and
Spotify and we will soon have this
podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you